for the decades leading up to 1971 the
u.s experienced a ton of real massive
growth workers went from making 675 a
year or 19 000 in today's money to more
than 56 thousand dollars in today's
money by the late 60s people enjoyed
paid leave and sick days for the first
time they could pay off student loans
buy houses and cars and enjoyed a
financially stable life payroll
increased by at least 32 percent in the
60s alone fiber optic cables leds
weather satellites the hard pacemaker
the internet d ran for computers lasers
were all invented in the 60s alone we
landed on the moon
the upper middle and lower classes were
all moving up together in harmony
but then 1971 hits and something really
weird happens the economy kept growing
except there was no longer everyone
getting richer together now it was only
the rich getting richer and the middle
and lower class basically flatlined to
this day
even with globalization even with the
computer revolution the internet
revolution the biotech revolution it
somehow has not added up to quite as
much of a difference as people thought
and if you were in the mid 1960s people
thought it was going to be the jetsons
you have vacation trips on the moon and
flying cars and robots doing all your
work and it hasn't quite happened it's
been just much slower right it's the
only robot that does any work that i'm
aware of is the roomba little carpet
sweeper there isn't as much progress
happening as advertised and that uh
rather than racing towards utopia or
dystopia the much bigger problem is one
of relative stagnation it sort of
manifests economically and that for the
first time we have a younger generation
that's not clearly doing better than
their parents
family incomes are up of some from the
late 60s but it's not clear that's the
right metric because you have a lot of
families where uh both spouses are
working and that's that's very different
from the world of of the late 60s
the inflation rate skyrocketed from
around 4 at the start of 1971 to more
than double at 8.8 percent in 1973. by
the end of the 70s it would go up to 12
household debt exploded exponentially
after 1971. so while lower and middle
class income stay stagnant they were
simultaneously getting shackled in debt
college tuition also suspiciously
started skyrocketing after 1971.
[Music]
and ask yourself how many new real
physical truly revolutionary
technologies like leds or fiber optics
have we really seen in the last few
decades besides reusable rockets
not much
something happened the rules of the game
were changed it was no longer a level
playing field and the best part is is
that it slipped right underneath the
noses of the middle and lower class and
all the signs point back to this one
year 1971 it was the year that
rearranged the very fabric of society as
we know it but to understand what
happened we have to take a journey all
the way back to world war one
and if you want some free bitcoin you
can earn up to 250 dollars in free
bitcoin for funding your account on
block five this is not financial advice
but i've already personally made 568
dollars and 74 cents in pure interest
just by keeping my crypto in my black
fight interest accounts i literally did
nothing to make this passive income
that's because block fight is a great
crypto platform that allows you to earn
up to nine percent apy on crypto that
you keep in your account
interest accrues daily and is paid
monthly there are no hidden fees no
minimum balances and no reason to wait
click the link below to open up your
account and get your free bitcoin now
thanks to block five for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
before world war one hit trade around
the world was conducted on a very simple
gold standard basically whatever you
wanted from another country you would
pay for any required weight of gold this
meant that countries that had lots of
stuff to export would have more gold
than countries who didn't have a lot to
export and before world war one the
system worked pretty well the
governments around the world kind of got
along perfectly which meant trading with
gold was simple and easy but then world
war one came around and threw the entire
system on its head the war brought a lot
of infighting and disagreements between
countries that used to work together it
put a lot of powerful countries in debts
they had to spend a lot of their gold
buying weapons and equipment to fight
against each other and gold reserves
started being spread around the world
much more thinly by the end of world war
one the u.s had a serious gold deficit
and once the great depression hit this
got even worse
so in 1930 the government pretty much
forced americans to exchange all the
gold they had for dollars they increased
the price of gold from 20 an ounce to 35
an ounce hoping that this would
discourage americans from buying gold in
the future this also meant that a lot of
foreign countries suddenly got
interested in trading their gold for
dollars since they would be getting so
much more money in exchange for their
gold almost every country that had a
natural gold source traded it with the
us for dollars by 1939 there was enough
gold in the world to replace all the
money in circulation then world war ii
hit and suddenly the us was dipping into
his gold reserves again and if they
thought world war one took a lot of
money world war ii was even worse the
two wars had wrecked the global
financial system and the simple gold
standard in government taxes just wasn't
enough to fund the crazy spending the
u.s had to do
something had to change enter the
bretton woods system
at bretton woods new hampshire delegates
from 44 allied and associate countries
arrived for the opening of the united
nations monetary and financial
conference
invited by president roosevelt to the
first major world financial meeting
since the london conference of 1933
they will work in the seclusion of this
white mountains resort at the end of the
war the 40 biggest and most important
governments in the world all came
together at the brennan woods hotel in
new hampshire to try to find a new
financial standard that would be less
likely to cause a global bankruptcy the
us had more than 75 percent of the
world's gold and the dollar was one of
the only currencies still linked to the
gold standard by then so the countries
agreed they would value their national
currencies relative to the dollar's
value in gold it was basically a very
indirect version of the gold standard
that pinned the value of the dollar at
35 dollars per ounce of gold all the
other countries of the world would
adjust the value of their currency
according to that and for a while it
worked the u.s stockpile is new gold
from countries who wanted to trade in
gold for dollars and the brandon wood
system became the new way to have a
stable currency after a chaotic war but
all things must come to an end and that
end came in the year 1971.
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so by the late 40s and early 50s the u.s
had a new superpower the ability to
print as much money as it needed for
whatever it wanted it wasn't supposed to
work like that there was supposed to be
a methodical decision-making process
that kept the amount of dollars in the
world equal to the amount of gold the
u.s has stockpiled but the temptation to
print money was just too great it was
like giving a child the keys to a candy
shop whenever there was a new national
development social program or massive
technological projects the us could just
print the money it needed to pay for it
after all dollars were as good as gold
with all this extra money the economy
obviously boomed but it wasn't
sustainable by 1955 america went to war
in vietnam and suddenly it needed a lot
more money than it had in gold the
vietnam war carried on for 20 years and
cost 168 billion dollars or around 1
trillion dollars in today's money to
fund it the government had to print
money like crazy and near the end this
reckless creation of new dollars finally
caught up with it you see other
countries started noticing that the us
was printing way more money than it
could possibly have in gold so they got
worried what if the president suddenly
announced that instead of 35 for an
ounce of gold it would be now 45 or 50
it would be the perfect way for the us
to stay afloat but it would mean
countries like the uk and france would
have to pay way more money to get their
gold back so the uk and france decided
to quit while they were still ahead and
france set a warship to new york to pick
up their gold
it was 1971 and president nixon was
having none of it so in one fell swoop
he declared a suspension of anyone's
ability to convert dollars into gold
i have directed the secretary of the
treasury to take the action necessary to
defend the dollar against the
speculators i have directed secretary
connelly to suspend temporarily the
convertibility of the dollar into gold
or other reserve assets except in
amounts and conditions determined to be
in the interest of monetary stability
and in the best interest of the united
states this short statement would become
one of the most pivotal moments in
history that hardly anyone knows the
importance of for the first time in
modern history the world's money was no
longer tied to anything for the first
time if you want to take people's wealth
if you want them to work for you as your
indentured slaves no longer did you have
to do it at the point of a gun or
through taxes both of which breeds
resentment now all you had to do was
print more money the more money you
printed the more of their wealth you
stole from them without them ever even
noticing it before it's too late because
the dollar amount in their bank account
stays the same but the value of those
dollars goes down what started in 1971
was the greatest con and wealth
redistribution scheme humanity has ever
seen and with it the bretton woods
system officially came to an end
[Music]
[Applause]
the money printer was let loose and the
chaos that resulted was subtle like
boiling a frog immediately the dollar's
value dropped at least 50 percent all
that new money pushed up the prices of
assets like real estate and stocks which
the rich own and the poor don't
furthering the divide what used to take
30 hours of work to buy one unit of a
publicly traded stock in 1860 would take
at least 126 hours of work today 1971
was also the year that the 30-year
mortgage standard was introduced which
meant that where you could have bought a
house for just three years salary in
1950 you're in debt for the next 30
years today instant money
m-o-n-e-y
in the form of a convenient personal
loan
so household debt explodes exponentially
college tuition explodes exponentially
the number of lawyers quadrupled and
what did all that debt and divide me
from middle and low income families over
half of americans live paycheck to
paycheck even when they make more than a
hundred thousand dollars a year most
americans that can save have less than
five thousand dollars in their savings
accounts and the income from the middle
and lower classes has stayed nearly the
same since 1971 while the upper class
continues to climb the modern pleb is a
debt slave draped in louis and today we
might be witnessing the grand finale of
the dollar almost a year ago i made a
video on how 40 of us dollars were
printed in the year 2020 one of our most
popular videos on the channel well today
the federal reserve has updated those
numbers and i redid the math it's no
longer 40 of all u.s dollars were
printed since 2020 not 50
not even 70 percent nope since january
2020 the u.s has printed nearly 80
percent of all u.s dollars in existence
80
m1
i literally had to do a double take when
i saw this number because what but yes
at the start of 2020 there was 4
trillion dollars in circulation and in
october 2021 there's over 20 trillion
dollars in circulation that means ladies
and gentlemen that the government has so
far robbed 80 of your wealth in the span
of under two years and although you may
only feel this theft and higher gas
prices and such so far it's probably
gonna get a lot worse
so what is the solution not financial
advice but one don't get into debt two
click the join button below for private
documentaries too controversial to be
released to the public to continue to
learn how the world really works and
three is to hedge your bets against the
us dollar and the money printer by
putting some money into crypto and one
crypto platform i've been using for a
while now is blockfi one of the easiest
places to store your crypto and earn
interest on it at the same time like i
mentioned before i've already earned 568
dollars and 74 cents in interest just by
keeping my crypto in my block fight
interest accounts i literally did
nothing to make this passive income all
you have to do is click the link below
open up your block file account fund
your account and you could get up to 250
in free bitcoin as a bonus for signing
up from there the platform allows you to
buy crypto instantly and directly from
your bank account and whatever crypto
you have in your blackfy account you'll
automatically earn up to nine percent
apy on it you can set up recurring
purchases so you can dollar cost average
into crypto which is what i have set up
and you don't have to wait to see your
purchases reflected in your blackfy
accounts there are no hidden fees and
you can start with as little as 20
today blackfy manages over 10 billion
dollars in assets globally it's on the
forest fintech 50 list and block fight
has over 1 million clients and 350
global institutions that use block fi
services so use the link below or go to
block fight.com jake to get up to 250 in
free bitcoin just for funding your
accounts and start earning interest on
your crypto today that's blockfy.com
jake with the link below thanks to
blockfi for sponsoring this video
[Music]
you